dernière prière du vendredi avant la fin
du ramadan certains ici prie pour que la
colère des palestiniens leur donne la
liberté
je crois que ça fera naître quelque
chose de body l'agenda myrha
dans le vieux gaza on forme plus
d'espoir dans la manifestation des
palestiniens que dans l'ardeur des
efforts diplomatiques
un cessez-le-feu on n'y croit pas
tellement
non on n'a jamais rien obtenu deux
disent allez parlant 10 israéliens on ne
peut pas leur faire confiance
la guerre continue et continue de
détruire de réclamer des vies
nous avons besoin de ces cinq jours dit
mohammed à propos d'une trêve temporaire
les israéliens aussi j'espère qu'ils
pourront s'asseoir et négocie 1 l'on
sait s'il veut nous avons besoin de paix
ici
mohamed habib tai shan zhai a depuis
l'offensive terrestre des forces
israéliennes l'endroit a plutôt des airs
de ville fantôme ceux qui s'y trouvent
profitent surtout d'une accalmie des
combats pour venir chercher quelques
effets personnels
l'accalmie des combats dans sa jahia ee
relative depuis notre arrivée on entend
le bourdonnement constant des drones au
dessus de nos têtes pas très loin dans
les rues avoisinantes le sont très
claires des combats rapprochés des tirs
d'armes légères et d'armes lourdes
la famille lé lot a décidé elle d'y
revenir quand même
nom mais je pars seul à pouvoir les
mettre à dos nous allons mourir dans nos
maisons mais nous ne quitterons pacha
zhai a dit nadia la famille dit que ce
sont les enfants qui ont demandé de
rentrer chez eux
j'avais peur mais quand j'ai vu les
corps coupés en morceaux des enfants je
n'ai plus eu peur je me dis que c'est
mieux de mourir à la maison et de vivre
dans la dignité dit la petite news sera
dix ans c'est pour ne pas la perdre que
les scénarios de cessez-le-feu proposé
sont inacceptables sans entre autres la
levée immédiate du blocus israélien de
l'enclavé palestinienne dit ce
porte-parole
nous voulons un cessez le feu mais un
cessez le feu sans notre liberté ce
n'est pas possible nous ne l'accepterons
pas nous n'avons rien à perdre c'est le
moment d'obtenir notre liberté
la liberté ou la mort ce n'est peut-être
pas le choix des fêtes anas et saad
escaffit impossible de leur poser la
question
les jumeaux de 18 ans sont morts au même
instant dans un bombardement israélien
cinq jours plus tard on vient tout juste
de retrouver leurs corps
ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada gaza